the Joe Rogan experience I do everything
in moderation and where I used to lift
super heavy for power like crazy heavily
used to be a big [ __ ] right 70
pounds bigger than I am now yeah well I
got to I benched my goal was to bench
over 500 now I bring any [ __ ]
emailing me I cheated right I used
steroids
and and I didn't know the [ __ ] I was
doing so but I tell you what when your
wiener breaks from taking that that will
make you stop doing anything that's what
happened I didn't [ __ ] I was doing but I
got to where I could lift pretty much
anything I wanted I couldn't walk from
me to Jamie and back without getting
winded and so do you like I mean I'll
just get its list what I took hinton
mash or so I was taken 250 milligrams or
one milliliter of a nan sate every three
days so basically I've taken three shots
a week of ananth 800 or stuff no it's
just testosterone to another 50
milligrams so I take one shot of that a
week now for being on testosterone
testosterone placement but I was also
taken eka poise that's four horses yes
it is and I was taking echo poise I was
taking that makes you super purple deca
I took trina-- bowling for a while but I
could not handle trendy like the [ __ ] I
hung a guide of a building like train is
not good it's super human strength
aggressive sex drive but superhuman
[ __ ] who like it's just not for me
so I only took that for a little bit and
I didn't take it for that long the one
thing I found out is one there's a
reason that you're not supposed to be on
that [ __ ] and I'm not a religious guy so
I'm not gonna say God didn't mean you to
be that way but somebody didn't mean me
to [ __ ] be that way
well you're monkeying with your your
structure you know you have a chemical
and biological and hormonal structure of
your body and you're monkeying with that
you know you're adding massive amounts
of muscle to your body you're adding
superhuman levels of hormones to your
body well and I you know I'm I'm 1/8
like the first time I took eka poise
it's a horse decongestant so it'll get
no the transmission yes it cleans out
the Airways or opens up the bronchial
dilator some hacking
[ __ ] up like what am I getting sick well
it's cuz I you know there's horses and
pigs on a [ __ ] container right
the idiot right so people ask me about
it I'm like don't do it eat healthier
you know work out hard like I lost
everything anyway but the problem was is
in the middle that they have deca and
it's good they call it deca dick right
it makes you like like no sex drive and
I wasn't taking anything - cuz I watched
her doll go right in the horse fell in
the pit was my daughter and I started
crying I don't said all girl is a movie
anyway horse falls in the pit and horse
gets like a spear in its leg I'm crying
I'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
well your emotional G's my estrogen
levels were like through the roof so I
looked and like an idiot I was taking I
had 200 milligrams per milliliter deca
and then I had another bottle that was
like 400 or something I got a mixed up
so I was doubling up on deck guess that
some of the Dumber she is for I maybe a
year and a half did you get yourself
checked out after it was over
oh yeah when I was okay well when I
first got off I was kind of photo I
don't feel pulling up how big I guess I
look like that rock on Fantastic Four
it's [ __ ] weird-looking dude I'm
Ronnie Coleman in here oh my god weeks
ago first of all what a great guy so
nice yeah looks so friendly and so so
happy even though he's basically broken
yeah he's had how many back surgeries
did he say he had something crazy yeah
like more than tens back surgery read an
article it's at 13 but and that was
probably it his entire back is basically
fused yeah but when you look at him when
he was mr. Olympia you know when he was
winning yeah Jesus yeah Jesus I mean
that a human being can get that big oh
it's it's insane and I mean I only
scratch like I didn't put the Camino he
done he's done it his whole life right
those guys are freaks Phil Heath lives
by us and Denver you'll see him every
now and there you used to and he's a new
kind of a one guy like Ronnie the thing
is though it's like you go into a gym
and grab two 200 pound dumbbells and you
start doing incline bench with no
spotter that steer you know grabbing
some looks but I junetta qila was not
built to lift that heavy right that
that's there's some help involved in
that but I got to a point where I was
super
and not like I don't believe really in
the roid-rage thing because I never got
that what I'm talking about you just
tell me you're hanging a guy outside of
a building that's why I'd rage yeah let
me finish good point but I think if you
just take an increased amount of like
testosterone and anabolic in general if
you're a happy guy you're happy if
you're a sad guy you're sad and if
you're a [ __ ] you're more of a
[ __ ] the thing with well trend
that's why I got off it that was one
thing for me that definitely I just I
was changing psychologically mm-hmm when
I got off it was the problem like
emotionally I was a wreck like that's
the closest I'm not like a suicidal guy
that's the closest where my brain just
didn't function right and then I got off
cold turkey and I whatever I do that is
a big issue with kids young kids there
are endocrine system crashes and just
like we were talking about with soldiers
that have been blown up a bunch or
football players or fighters your body's
not producing testosterone correctly
after you get off that [ __ ] you get
really really depressed for some people
bigger XE is what they were telling me
cuz I was afraid to go to the gym
because I was shrinking
[Applause]